it's design week and our next guest
doesn't believe that you need to break
the bank to beautify your home she was
recognized by good housekeeping as an
interior designer who is changing the
world she's the contributing editor of
house beautiful my favorite and the
founder of kingston design connection
please welcome interior designer
extraordinaire marilyn demour
[Applause]
thank you so much for having me on i
can't believe i'm here oh my god i'm so
honored you are really one of my
favorite designers i follow everything
you do
um what is your biggest design tip
what's budget-friendly design advice um
you know this is something i tell my
clients all the time that
the simplest thing to do is plan ahead
and we do this as interior designers all
the time in terms of developing mood
boards and renderings because at the end
of the day you can change anything on
paper as many times as you want and
something as even inexpensive as paint
if you need to repaint that that can get
pretty costly pretty quickly so taking
the time to do all of that stuff on
paper means that when you're ready to go
there are fewer missteps all right we're
having a new homeowner with her design
dilemma a few upgrades that are under 30
let's take a look
hi drew my name is julie i live in
brewster new york with my husband and
two small boys about seven months ago we
bought our new house and we need help
the previous owners gifted us this hutch
and dining set and although it's
beautiful it's just really not our style
and it doesn't work for us in this room
i would love to get rid of the hut
except then it leaves this huge blank
wall that i do not know what to do with
do you have any tips that could help me
maximize the space please help us we'd
be so grateful thank you
please welcome julie miller
thank you for coming on the show
okay so um marilyn take us through
your suggestions your insight i want to
hear everything so i'm putting it over
to you so one of the first things that i
did was to find a lovely floral
wallpaper so that way your dining room
can be surrounded in springtime
and we definitely got rid of the hutch
okay so we wanted you to keep the
storage that you had
so we brought in these lovely floating
shelves
and you can see that you can mix them up
it can be shelving for your dinnerware
as well as books etc and we framed it
out in lovely framing
and you have two children i understand
it's crazy it is a crazy time i think we
should as a society agree
it's a buckle up absolutely you know so
i'm definitely of the mindset that we
should be creating children's spaces in
our homes and even if it's an elegant
space there's an elegant way to include
children in our homes so one of the ways
that i did that was to bring in a
chalkboard at children level
oh my god as you can see
yes it is so
oh my god this is just and to cook a
meal like your kids can color while you
cook a meal like and not on your table
they can color on the chocolate i love a
good game of tic-tac-toe
all right what is your vision for the
dining table set what did you do here
so your dining table and chair set were
dark wood all of it yes right so we
actually lightened it up
so that way your space is light and
bright and airy and so one of the ways
we did that was through these foot
covers no i don't know why i didn't
think of this yeah and they need to do
yeah and since you have children it's
easy to swap them out throw them in the
washing machine marilyn can you buy
pre-made slip covers that kind of
generically fit a chair yes absolutely
well julie what do you think
i'm so in love oh my gosh it is like
it is so beautiful oh my god it is
everything the table oh my god my
pinterest
this is my pinterest one thing i want to
point out that we're talking about all
throughout the week that has definitely
influenced me as of late as well is the
pops of black i think it's really kind
of rising to the top of a really great
way to minimalistically or as a
maximalist really shake up your space
yeah absolutely
[Applause]
[Applause]
and we're gonna give you 500 to just get
it installed make it all happen oh my
god just everything dialed in thank you
so much
[Music]